So, you could either choose to subtract the c or divide by a first. It doesn't
matter which order you do these in, as long as you obey all the proper
mathematical rules. In particular, when we divide both sides by a, make sure
that you divide every term on each side by a, and do that division correctly.
The first time I did this, I actually messed up dealing with the second term in
the left-hand side. I didn't write a squared, I just didn't write an a at all in
the denominator. So, everyone makes mistakes. It's not a big deal if you do. We
just gotta keep learning from them. Anyway, the equation we end up with at the
end of this step is the quantity x plus b over 2a squared minus b squared over
4a squared equals negative c over a.